[Applause]
always by the queen's side
tolerance is the one essential
ingredient of any happy marriage
prince philip was a devoted consort and
father
i am so happy my future husband
is by my side he was a fun parent to
have around
and very conscious of spending time with
the children
when he could shaping his
own legacy through his charity work
5 000 quid which will go a long way to
help a great many families
i think we better get on with the
celebrations now thank you very much his
straight talking manner
and commitment to his country
embodying the values of the wartime
generation
born in corfu in 1921 prince philip of
greece
and denmark was welcomed into a world of
title
and privilege but when he was still a
baby his family were forced to flee
their home
a military coup meant it was no longer
safe to stay in greece
when the family were on board this boat
that the sailors
looked at the infant prince philip who
was only 18 months old at the time
and decided that the best place for him
would be this orange crate
from which they fashioned us a sort of
crib and there he slept during the
journey
effectively homeless they eventually
made their way to paris
while money was tight it was a happy
time for philip
surrounded by his parents and sisters
it wouldn't last when he was eight his
mother was diagnosed with paranoid
schizophrenia
his mother was then tragically confined
to um what was called in those days
an asylum for mental for the mentally
disturbed
it was the more tragic because philip
was not told what had happened to his
mother
she just vanished from his life i mean
it's difficult for me to imagine how on
earth
he coped with the sort of family life
that he had
and i think he hugely valued
the family life and and
people coming together and and being
there for each other
with his parents separated he moved
around boarding schools in britain
eventually settling at gordenstein in
scotland it
turned him into the entirely reliable
person that he was i mean he
learned very early that he had to really
stand on his own two feet
as soon as he left school a career in
the navy was calling
while training at dartmouth naval
college another chapter of his life
would open
during a royal visit he was asked to
escort king george vi
his wife and two daughters including
princess elizabeth
was included in the royal party i think
her heart was lost then i mean he was
a god-like good-looking he must have
been about 18 i think
i i think i did suppose that he
fell in love with her i'm sure he would
have very much enjoyed
her company and thought she was a rather
unusual child
for her age and
i think it wasn't long before it
developed into something rather
different
six weeks after that visit britain would
go to war
philip was first sent to the indian
ocean and then the mediterranean where
he'd serve on
hms valiant his efforts during the
battle of cape matapan against the
italian ships
was mentioned in dispatches like so many
elizabeth and philip would stay in touch
during the war
by writing letters it was quite a lot of
correspondence went on
and they probably managed to to to meet
occasionally
he was a bachelor again remember this is
war time and you don't know whether
you're really going to get blown out of
the sea the next
uh the next morning uh adds a certain
sort of frisson to the
to the to the whole of next for november
20th lieutenant mountbatten returns to
the naval training center
as conflict came to an end not everyone
was happy about elizabeth's continuing
infatuation most notably her parents
queen elizabeth i think wasn't quite
sure about this good looking young man
also where was his family where'd he go
to school what was this place
gordenstrom
nobody had heard of it prince philip had
joined the royal navy
very good mentioned in dispatches but
it's not the brigade of guards is it
but in 1947 their engagement
was announced for the famous balcony
came the bride and bridegroom
in the gloom of post-war britain the
wedding was a cause for celebration
[Applause]
the duke of edinburgh and his duchess
soon settled into married life
their first two children charles and
then ann were born
he was a fun parent to have around and
very conscious of spending time with the
children
when he could the more you known about
him
and his life i think the more impressed
and the more proud i become
of what not only he achieved as an
individual but how he translated that
in into the rest of his life and that is
an example which
uh i would hope to be to be able to
follow
philip continued to rise through the
navy he was posted in malta where his
wife would visit
a chance for them to spend time together
as a couple they're taking the places of
the king and queen who would have gone
but for his majesty's illness
but in 1952 as they were beginning a
tour of the commonwealth
everything changed to the stunned heart
of london
and to the whole commonwealth came the
tragic news from sandringham
of the passing of a beloved sovereign
king george vi
princess elizabeth and prince philip
were in such a remote place
in a hunting lodge in kenya it was
difficult to contact them
the word came through it was given
initially to the duke of edinburgh of
course he immediately
went to tell his young wife the news
that her father her
much loved father had died
a year later came the coronation
his wife was now queen he was her
consort
next the duke of edinburgh preceding the
other royal dukes
she understood the limitations that he
willingly
took on in his life as a very masculine
man
being always one step behind his wife
and there was no disguising his obvious
pleasure
at being back amongst his former
shipmates
with his wife settling into her new role
he was forced to give up
his career in the navy in a rare
interview he talked about how difficult
that decision was to make
i do perfectly well go on with this
career i didn't seem to
and it would have seemed to me would
have been a great value to the
to the queen when she became queen
eventually to have somebody who was
in a sense professionally qualified at
something
not just traipsing around
outwardly dedicated and seemingly
compliant
there was however the issue of whether
his children would take his name
windsor won out over mountbatten i don't
think she
quite realized that it was really going
to have a very deep effect on prince
philip
as he said that i must be the only man
in the whole country was not allowed to
pass his name on to his children
prince philip would carve out his own
path
traveling across the country and around
the world promoting his favorite causes
from british industry three out of every
five gas turbines flying or on order in
the entire western world
are british to the environment
there are exciting opportunities to
protect some very significant habitats
and doing his bid to help young people
so i wasn't prepared for this so i think
we better get on with the celebrations
now
out of the 800 charities he supported
the duke of edinburgh's award scheme
was one of his biggest achievements
300 000 young people are doing this
award at any one time
and what they're getting is this
life-changing experience the duke's
relationship with young people was
actually quite a surprising thing
the way in which he engaged with young
people when he met with them
was extraordinary to see i'm very active
lots of interest and and constantly
encouraged us in all sorts of get
involved in all sorts of activities and
and that's been you know that's the bit
that we will always remember
when his wife needed him for overseas
tours
garden parties and the big state
occasions
he was for decades of constant by his
side
the main lesson that we've learned is
that tolerance
is the one essential ingredient of any
happy marriage
it may not be quite so important when
things are going well
but it is absolutely vital when things
get
and you can take it from me that the
queen has the quality of tolerance and
abundance
i think particularly for a woman in a
role
such as she has um i think it would be a
very lonely place to be
um if she didn't have uh a life partner
the way that she has with with prince
philip um and
he's you know he's he's a strong
character he's someone
she can lean on um he has his own
interests as well as the interests
of of the queen as well he sort of has
her back really
i don't think he got involved in
constitutional issues that he shouldn't
have got involved in
but for instance the christmas broadcast
which was a
an ordeal for the queen um the duke
was probably the most important person
who she consulted
just on the text and the language
out of the public eye he was also
someone his four children could turn to
lots of different members of the family
would of always find him
a good person a good sounding board
but it was always done very quietly and
he would never talk to anybody else
about
his conversations
the family is very close together and
and we do
enjoy spending time school will break up
in july and that would be for me the
sort of the phony holiday so we go off
and do different things but
my parents really didn't uh weren't
really able to escape until august
and that was always really frustrating
because we get to to get to balmoral in
in um
you know sort of sort of mid-august and
uh
it was great fun but i was only there
for about two weeks and it was off back
to school again
as one by one his children's marriages
failed the 1990s were some of the most
testing years
amid the scandal and divorce proceedings
there was also a fire at windsor castle
in 1997 princess diana was killed in a
car crash
they were criticized for staying in
scotland keeping the princes away from
london
it was hard for the duke to see his wife
under attack
it was in fact prince philip who
encouraged prince william to walk behind
his mother's coffin
but it was clear that william didn't
want to walk behind the coffin just
felt it would be difficult and he said
to prince william
you may regret this if you don't walk in
the procession in years to come
you may regret not having been there so
prince philip said
if
in those difficult years he had little
time for the press
are you well sir do i look ill
in an age of increasing political
correctness philip at times became as
well known for his gaffes
as his good work a reputation he wasn't
fond of
an outburst at a battle of britain event
just one
that made the headlines some of the most
famous gaffes this was probably the
thousandth person he was shaking hands
with that week
he could see that they were stuck and
they didn't quite know what to say next
and
he was trying to jolly them along
many of those closest to him would argue
he was
full of fun helping his wife to
modernize the monarchy
making them more accessible sometimes on
really rather stiff occasions
the people would be lined up in a
ghastly long
semicircle and the queen would go one
way the duke would go the other and
you'd hear gales of laughter
coming from the duke side and that made
things better on the queen side as well
duke vendor always notices the little
one who's got a flower that
she he or she wants to give to the queen
and there are
many many photographs and footage of him
picking the child up taking it over the
barrier and then
you know letting the child go and give
the flower to the queen and then
he's he's always he always notices
things like that
[Music]
it was following the diamond jubilee
pageant that he was forced into hospital
with a bladder infection
[Applause]
this was the queen's milestone but also
a reminder
of the public's affection for her
husband ladies and gentlemen if we shout
loud enough
he might just hear us in hospital
around his 90th birthday he did admit he
was slowing down
a little i mean can you get radio three
of us
but it wasn't until he was 96 that he
retired from his own
program of royal duties
in retirement he stayed active his
independent spirit
brought into the spotlight when he was
involved in a car crash
and then spotted driving 48 hours later
occasionally in his latter years he
would still appear alongside the queen
for big events and
family celebrations
[Music]
in 2020 he made an unexpected public
appearance to hand over one of his
longest standing military patronages
in the year that he also marked his 99th
birthday
it was his marriage that would place
prince philip at the center
of national life as well known for his
humor
as his charity work a man with a deep
sense of duty to his family his country
and his queen he has quite simply
been my strength and stay all these
years
and i and his whole family and this
and many other countries owe him a debt
greater than he would ever claim
for we shall ever know